الهجمات الاوكرانيه العابره للحدود تتصدر
المشهد في الحرب المتواصله بين روسيا
واوكرانيا فبعد طي صفحه معركه باخمت
باعلان موسكو السيطره عليها تحولت الانظار
صوب الهجمات المتكرره لاوكرانيا داخل
الاراضي التابعه لروسيا اخر هذه الهجمات
تلك التي استهدفت مدينه
القرم فنقلا عن ميخائيل
ارزعمده مدينه
لروسيا في شبه جزيره القرم فان انظمه
الحرب الالكترونيه والبحريه في المدينه
صدت هجوما شنته طائره مسيره بدوره قال
اكسيونوف حاكم القرم ان الدفاعات الجويه
الروسيه اسقطت سته طائرات مسيره في اماكن
متنوعه بالمنطقه وفي المنطقه ذاتها حمل
برلمان شبه جزيره القرم اوكرانيا
المسؤوليه عن عمليه تخريب السكك الحديديه
في سيمبيروفول والتي ادت الى خروج قطار
لشحن الحبوب عن مساره
ونزيف الهجمات الاوكرانيه على الاراضي
الروسيه مستمر في اماكننا متعدده فنقلا عن
جهاز الامن الفيدرالي الروسي فقد تم احباط
هجوم ارهابي خطط له من قبل جهاز المخابرات
الاوكراني على محطات الطاقه النوويه في
منطقتي
وكالينين الهجوم كان يسعى لتفجير حوالي 30
خط نقل كهربائي في المحطات
ومن الشمال الروسي الى الجنوبه حيث تجددت
الهجمات في منطقه حيث اعلنت سلطات المدينه
الروسيه ادى القوات الاوكرانيه اطلقت 84
قذيفه خلال الساعات 24 الاخيره ما ادى الى
اندلاع حرائق في المنطقه وكانت ذات
المقاطعه قد تعرضت قبل ايام لتسلل مجموعه
تخريبيه اوكرانيه الى اراضيها فضلا عن
تعرضها لهجوم شرس بطائرات مسيره
وفي سلسله الهجمات الاوكرانيه ايضا اعلنت
البحريه الروسيه احباط هجوم على سفينه
حربيه اثناء قيامها بدوريه في المياه
الاقليميه التركيه واتهمت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه الجيش الاوكراني بتنفيذ الهجوم
باستخدام ثلاث زوارق مسيره جرى تدميرها
يضاف الى كل هذه الهجمات الاوكرانيه
الهجوم الذي تعرض له الكرملين مطلع شهر
مايو الجاري بطائرات مسيره هجوم كشفت
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز نقلا عن المخابرات
الامريكيه
ان وحده خاصه تابعه للجيش او المخابرات
الاوكرانيه هي التي تكون قد دبرتها
الهجمات الاوكرانيه العابره للحدود اذا
شكلت نقله نوعيه في الاستراتيجيه الحربيه
للجيش الاوكراني وحول الغرض من هذه
الهجمات نشرت صحيفه نيويورك الامريكيه
تحليلا اعتبرت في ان الهدف منها هو محاوله
كييف تشتيت تركيز الجيش الروسي في اتجاهات
مختلفه لفتح ثغرات جديده كما اضافت ان
ترغب ايضا من خلال هذه التوهلات التمهيد
للهجوم المضاد الذي تخطط له
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات